-Can we talk about
the "Drag Race"?
-The "Drag Race."
-Yeah.
-Which is starting February --
[ Laughter ]
February 28th, it's starting
It's starting.
-The "Drag Race."
[ Laughter ]
The Weeknd ain't on there.
The Weeknd is not on
the "Drag Race."
[ Laughter ]
-No. The "Drag Race."
I know -- "Drag Race" --
you've won so many Emmys.
-Several many.
-That is --
-Several many Emmys.
And it's a fantastic show.
-It's a fantastic show.
-I love the show. It is fun.
It is positive.
-Yeah.
-It is about acceptance.
It's about love. And it's just
really good for the brain.
-It is.
-I do.
-And it's got a lot
of drag queens on there.
-It really does. It does hav
a lot of drag queens.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Why do people connect
to the show, do you think?
-You know, honestly,
I this think it has to do with
the tenacity
of the human spirit.
Everybody wants to root
for the underdog.
And these kids have come
from homes where they mom
and they daddy have
thrown them out.
But they said,
"You know what, Mama?
You know what, Daddy?
Eff y'all!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'ma do my own thing!
I'ma do my -- Mama, you do you
Daddy, you do you.
I'ma do me.
I'ma go on RaPool,
"RuPaul Drag Race.'
-The "Drag Race."
[ Laughter ]
-And I'm gonna do my thang
And you know, eff y'all.
That's all."
And look, she done
on the cover of a magazine
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know?
-You're right.
And Nicki Minaj is a guest judge
on the first episode.
-Young money, baby.
-Yeah, Nicki Minaj.
-Young money!
-We love Nicki Minaj.
-Yeah, Nicki Minaj.
-Love that.
-Nicki Minaj-a.
-You play -- You play a lo
of games on the show. Fun.
-Yes, we do. I love games.
-I love games, too.
-You know, Jimmy, my favorit
thing in the world to do
is to laugh.
It's my favorite thing
in the world to do.
-That makes two of us.
-Yes.
-I enjoy it, as well.
-Yeah.
-What games would you play
on your show?
-Well, anywhere can I go,
I will play dirty charades
You know?
You know regular charades.
-Yeah.
-Well, this is dirty charades,
where you just change one word
in the title.
You know? You have a movie o
a book or a TV show or a song.
-Okay.
-Jimmy. And you change one word.
And I -- I sent over
a bunch of --
I think I sent over 30 titles.
The standards and practice
rejected every single
one of them.
-Is there any one that we ca
get away with?
-I think so. I think so.
You guys want to play
dirty charades?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Can I do one for you?
-Please.
All right, ready?
-I'm going to do one for you
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay, here we go.
All right. Here we go. Um, um...
-Movie.
Three words.
-Um -- And you know this means
total concept, right?
Okay.
-Yeah.
-Total concept. All right.
-Total concept.
-Okay, all right, okay.
Here we go.
♪♪♪♪
-"Saturday Night Fever."
"Saturday Night Fever."
-Okay.
-Third word.
-Beaver!
-"Saturday Night Beaver"?
-Yes!
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Yes!
-Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my gosh.
You are just in big trouble.
I want to share --
I want to show everyone a clip
Here's RuPaul introducing th
judges in the season premiere --
you're in so much trouble --
of "RuPaul's Drag Race."
Take a look at this.
♪♪♪♪
-♪♪ Let your whole body talk
-Welcome to the main stage
of "Nicki Minaj's Drag Race.
[ Laughter ]
I'm so glad you're here.
Young Money in the house!
[ Rolls tongue ]
[ Laughter ]
Her anaconda do,
Michelle Visage.
-You should know what
my anaconda do.
[ Laughter ]
-Style superstar,
Carson Kressley. You ready
-I'm ready to pound the alarm.
-Yes!
-Even though I've never pounde
anything in my life.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah?
-Not yet.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh. We love Carson.
RuPaul, break a leg on
"Saturday Night Live"
on Saturday.
-Thank you.
-We'll be watching.
We love you.
And please come back
whenever you want to.
-I would love to.
-RuPaul, everyone.